welcome to the program Ukraine's
President says he's headed to the U.S
for talks with Joe Biden in his first
foreign trip since the Russian invasion
began in February Vladimir zielinski
tweeted to say that he is on his way to
strengthen resilience and defense
capabilities of Ukraine the leader has
also confirmed he will address the U.S
Congress and hold several bilateral
meetings Washington has been Keith's
biggest supporter with some 20 billion
dollars in military assistance so far
the White House has released a statement
saying President Biden will announce a
significant new package of security
assistance to help Ukraine defend itself
against Russian aggression
Melinda Herring is a Ukraine specialist
and deputy director of the Atlantic
council's Eurasia Center she says
solenski's Security will be a top
priority
it's a big deal because there are
enormous security concerns we know that
the Russians wanted to whack for
Vladimir zielinski back in February so
this uh this visit had to be kept a
secret it was a secret until the 11th
hour until it was no longer a secret I
think it's also significant that he's
coming to Washington first to say thank
you to President Biden and that he's
also going to Congress so he I expect
him to spend most of his time and energy
on Capitol Hill because he knows that
Capital Hill has the most sympathy and
can do the most for him I think he's
less concerned about Congress than we
were you know three three months ago it
looks like Congress is going to continue
the same policies toward Ukraine on on
weapons in particular Republicans are
solid where Republicans are not solid
and where I'm worried is budget support
and this is the category of money it's
billions of dollars that taxpayers are
giving to make sure that the Ukrainian
state stays afloat and that is
controversial among Republicans you need
three things to get Ukraine through the
winter sure you need air defense systems
and there aren't enough air defense
systems to protect uh Ukraine because
it's such a big country it needs
airplanes so I hope zelinski I expect
him to bring that up with President
Biden and say come on we need more
airplanes in order to fight this and
also please help us with the emergency
assistance to keep our electrical grid
alive we don't know how many more
strikes uh the system can take before it
goes down
let's bring in Charles Stratford who
joins us live now from cave hello there
Charles this visit certainly signals the
importance of Ukraine's relationship
with the US doesn't it
it certainly does and of course it comes
at a critical time in the wake of these
weeks of missile and Kamikaze drone
strikes against ukrainian's vital energy
infrastructure more than a thousand we
understand
um in these recent weeks and uh yeah it
underscores the kind of Reliance that
zielinski um has on Western weapons on
Western support and the U.S in
particular we understand that this new
um this new arms package that is going
to be announced in Washington could be
another to worth another two billion
dollars that's already on top of a
commitment of what 18.5 billion dollars
from the US a lot of focus is going to
be on whether we're going to hear an
announcement finally about these Patriot
missile systems that the ukrainians have
been asking for for so long this has
been a hugely controversial subject um
previously the Biden Administration has
said no it wouldn't be sending this kind
of Weaponry because it was so Advanced
and there were fears it's understood
that this could be seen as an escalation
by Russia or an Escalade Moscow could
see it as an escalation and of course
there are huge challenges in using these
weapons they are very complex
um to use they involve a lot of training
some analysts say that Patriot missile
training can take up to a year we don't
know whether that training has started
certainly isn't in this country but
there are some analysts saying that
training May well have started in some
of the European countries people have
been talking about Germany as I say
they're very very complex to use they're
very expensive each missile can cost
between three and five million dollars
but they're seen as vital in in boosting
the air defense of this country
um so yeah it's gonna be very
interesting to see whether we finally
get an announcement on that and as you
as you heard the analysts there say
there's going to be a lot of talk about
possible additional sanctions an
additional Weaponry that is needed and
it's interesting that this visit comes a
day after the Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski was on the front line
in Us in the town of bakmut where there
is the most intense fighting going no
gains really being made by either side
but we know that thousands of soldiers
both ukrainians and Russians have been
killed in what they describe as being
described as the bakmut meat grinder a
real war of attrition there so yes this
visit is of huge significance hopefully
for the ukrainians it's going to give
them more weapons more support and it is
a very strong signal to the Kremlin of
Vladimir Putin in Russia it certainly is
thank you very much for that update as
always Charles Stratford live for us in
cave
and as Charles mentioned earlier
zielinski visited the Eastern Frontline
city of bakmut the region is the latest
epicenter in the conflict with some of
the heaviest fighting with Russians
local sources told Al Jazeera Russian
forces and fighters from the Wagner
group have lost some of their positions
on the southern side of the city control
of mahmut would give the Kremlin a boost
in their battle for the donbass region
I want to say that we see what remains
of where they left Nothing is alive this
issue isn't just in the donbass that is
why I want to tell you here in donbass
you protect the whole of Ukraine because
after donbass they will do all this in
other cities of our country because they
don't want anything Ukrainian I am 100
sure of this and therefore the
protection of the whole of Ukraine rests
on your shoulders not just on bus